-I'm Jannis Niewöhner.
-And I'm George MacKay.
We're from the cast of
Munich - The Edge of War.
And we're going to attempt
to answer questions,
whilst playing Jenga.
-Keep it cool man.
-Pals.
Let me start with this one
down here.
Careful.
30th September?
You went specific. 1938?
One week to shoot a scene.
The whole scene was
supposed to be in English,
but then it was supposed
to be in German.
You had one week
to learn all the lines,
so it's definitely George.
-Already?
-I know what you mean.
-I think the Brow house one?
-Absolutely, yeah.
We had to improvise a bit,
right?
Bring our own arguments
to the scene,
to the discussion
and that was really--
I was scared of that.
The people of a whole county
forgot about
what makes them as a nation
and now that there is
someone to lead them
and to remind them
of their nation's greatness.
I had to keep it cool,
like now
Yeah.
It was just like this.
We were playing Jenga
but it got edited out.
Fucking hell.
We'll leave that there.
We're both pretty good
in the morning.
I love an early morning sun.
I'm gonna say Jannis,
just 'cause I really like
early mornings.
It's definitely George.
It's making it wobble.
I think maybe the argument
in the car.
There's other ways
of doing thing.
There's talk,
there's discussion
There's no other things. No!
There's always hope.
You know, we did that again,
and again, and again.
That we were sort
of speaking
and kind of get to
log ahead.
The big, amazing hotel
in Dresden
Yeah, that was great.
Which kind of,
doubled as the area
before the meeting
took place.
The place were,
all the kind of,
political parties
were staying.
That was an amazing hotel
in Dresden.
Dresden was an amazing city.
It is!
It is now.
We got it!
Should I take this out
really fast?
-Yeah.
-I think I can do it.
Cut, cut, cut.
Let me do it again.
Magic.
Munich - The Edge of War
is now streaming.